This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Around the summer of 2023, 99PI producer Vivienne Lay decided her life was in need of an upgrade. Oh god, yes. That's Vivienne. My husband and I were dying to move into a new apartment. We've jumped around a lot from place to place, and our previous residences included a rundown dingbat, a basement studio with
这里是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。2023年夏天前后，99PI的制作人薇薇安·莱（Vivienne Lay）决定要提升一下自己的生活品质。天哪，没错。那就是薇薇安。我和我丈夫当时特别渴望搬进一套新公寓。我们之前搬过很多次家，住过破旧的“丁字形”公寓（dingbat），住过结构安全性存疑的地下室工作室，还住过我妈家，所以我们已经准备好过上奢华的生活了。在Zillow上搜索了很久之后，我们终于在洛杉矶一个适合步行的街区找到了一栋高档公寓楼，里面有游泳池、健身房，还有一个神级的便利设施：中央空调。欢迎来到美好生活，薇薇。谢谢，我们当时非常兴奋。但在搬家那天，当我正拖着箱子穿过大厅时，我发现了一些在最初看房时被我忽略的东西。贴在我那漂亮的新公寓楼入口处
questionable structural integrity, and my mom's house, so we were ready to live luxuriously. And after a long Zillow search, we ended up finding a bougie apartment building in a walkable neighborhood of Los Angeles, with a pool, a gym, and a god-tier amenity, Central AC. Welcome to the good life, Viv. Thank you, we were very excited. But on move-in day, as I was schlepping boxes through the lobby doors, I spotted something that slipped my attention during the initial walkthrough. Stuck to the entrance of my beautiful new apartment building
是一个看起来很不祥的标志。上面写着：警告，进入此区域可能会使您接触到加利福尼亚州已知会导致癌症、出生缺陷或其他生殖危害的化学物质，包括苯（一种用于小便池清洁剂的化学物质）和甲苯（一种用于常见家用清洁产品的化学物质）。欲了解更多信息，请访问 www.p65warnings.ca.gov。这就是“65号提案”（Proposition 65）的警告。你可以在所有在加利福尼亚州制造或分销的各类产品上找到这些标签。它们通常都有类似的措辞，关键词以“警告”开头，
was an ominous looking sign. It read, warning, entering this area can expose you to chemicals known to the state of California to cause cancer and birth defects or other reproductive harm, including benzene, a chemical used in urinal cleaners, and toluene, a chemical used in common household cleaning products. For more information, go to www.p65warnings.ca.gov. This was a Proposition 65 warning. You can find these labels on all sorts of products manufactured in or distributed to the state of California. They generally all have similar language, with buzzwords starting with warning,
紧接着是“化学物质”、“癌症”、“出生缺陷”。对于加利福尼亚州以外的人来说，这样的标签看起来可能非常可怕。也许你曾经订购过在圣地亚哥制造的卧室家具，然后发现自己在谷歌上搜索：“灯罩会导致我得癌症吗？”问号。但对于我们这些住在这里的人来说，
and quickly followed by chemical, cancer, birth defects. For people who live outside the state of California, a label like this might look pretty terrifying. Maybe you've at one point ordered bedroom furniture manufactured in San Diego and found yourself Googling, can I get cancer from a lampshade? Question mark. But for those of us who do live here,
没有什么比“65号提案”警告标签更常见、更具加州特色的了。作为一个在加州生活了一辈子的人，我见过各种东西上都有这种标签，从电动工具到皮夹克，再到薯片、膳食补充剂、餐具、加油泵、咖啡桌、停车场。我在太多不同的东西上见过这些标签，以至于当我看到我即将搬入的这栋五层楼、169个单元的公寓楼上也有它时，我并没有惊慌失措，也没有搬走，甚至没有质疑“你指的甲苯是什么意思”。我只是像往常看到这些标签时一样，继续过我的一天。这让我不禁想问，如果像我这样的人只是无视它们，这些警告到底有什么用呢？嗯，其实用处很大，因为事实证明，这些丑陋、笨拙的警告标签，不知何故竟是我们解决一个更丑陋、更笨拙的环境问题时，所能拥有的最
there are a few things more common or more Californian than a Proposition 65 warning label. As a California lifer, I've seen them on everything from power tools to leather jackets to potato chips to dietary supplements, dishware, gas pumps, coffee tables, parking garages. I've seen these labels on so many different things that by the time I saw it on the five-story 169 unit apartment building that I was moving into I didn't panic or move apartment buildings or even question What toll you mean is I just carried on with my day like I always do whenever I see these labels on anything Which made me wonder what good these warnings are even doing if people like me are just ignoring them. Well, kind of a lot, because it turns out these ugly, clunky warning labels are somehow the most
优雅的方案。要追溯这些设计拙劣的警告的起源，你需要和这个人谈谈。我们可能快要有进展了。我能听到那个声音。而讽刺的是，在我们的采访过程中，他被一个设计拙劣的警告打断了。它说：“所有人保持冷静。”完美。顺便说一下，这个人是戴维·罗（David Rowe）。25年来，我一直是一名高级律师，
elegant solution we've got for tackling an even uglier, clunkier environmental problem. To trace the origin of these poorly designed warnings, you need to talk to this man. We may be getting somewhere. I can hear that. Who, ironically, was interrupted by a poorly designed warning during our interview. Everyone remain calm, it says. Perfect. This man, by the way, is David Rowe. For 25 years, I was a senior lawyer
就职于环境保卫基金会（Environmental Defense Fund）。1985年，我起草了一项名为“65号提案”的投票提案，用于1986年的投票。80年代中期对于环境律师来说可能是一个疯狂的时期，因为当时一切都是毒药。当时，洛杉矶平均每年有273天空气质量处于危险水平。在过去五年里，发生了近7000起涉及有毒化学品的事故，造成超过135人死亡。
with the Environmental Defense Fund, and in 1985, I wrote a ballot proposition called Proposition 65 for the 1986 ballot. The mid-80s was probably a wild time to be an environmental lawyer because everything was poison. At the time, Los Angeles was averaging a total of 273 hazardous air quality days a year. There had been nearly 7,000 accidents involving toxic chemicals, which killed over 135 people
加州州议会宣布，儿童铅暴露是该州最严重的环境健康问题，近一半的加州人不敢喝自来水。它是大地的生命之源，但这种大自然给予人类最基本的馈赠，现在却带有威胁。有些人喝着受污染的水，却不知道水受到了污染。美国在保护人们免受有毒化学品侵害方面的记录并不好。
in the past five years alone. The California state legislature declared childhood lead exposure the most significant environmental health problem in the state state and nearly half of Californians Were afraid to drink their tap water It's the giver of life to the earth But this most elemental offering of nature to man now carries a threat There are people drinking water that's contaminated and they don't know that the water's contaminated. The United States does not have a good record
像FDA（食品药品监督管理局）和EPA（环境保护署）这样的联邦机构本应保护人类健康和环境。但即使在1985年，监管有毒化学品的法律意图与实际影响之间仍然存在巨大的差距。我最喜欢的例子是《清洁空气法》（Clean Air Act）中的有毒物质部分。
when it comes to keeping people safe from toxic chemicals. Federal agencies like the FDA and the EPA were created to protect human health and the environment. But even in 1985, there were still huge gaps between the intent of laws regulating toxic chemicals and impact. My favorite example was the toxic section of the Clean Air Act.
《清洁空气法》最初于1963年通过，由EPA执行。在当时，这是一项具有里程碑意义的环境法，旨在为空气中的某些污染物设定限值。戴维说，这在理论上很好，但在执行中，实际上并没有完成多少工作。该立法说：“这里有189种化学物质。”
The Clean Air Act was originally passed in 1963 and is enforced by the EPA. At the time, it was a landmark environmental law that aimed to set limits on certain pollutants in the air. David said it was great in theory, but in execution, not much was actually getting done. The legislation said here are 189 chemicals.
“这些是我们希望你们弄清楚多少剂量算过量的物质，然后去把它们禁掉，而不仅仅是规定多少剂量算过量。”好吧，在20年里，他们只设法为189种化学物质中的6种设定了限值。化学公司和游说团体抵制联邦监管，因为他们认为改变行为既昂贵又给企业带来了负担。戴维想真正让改变行为符合他们的利益。如果这在联邦层面无法实现，那么就在州层面实现。
Those are the ones we want you to figure out how much is too much for and then go around and start banning them for things beyond how much is too much. Well, in 20 years, they had managed to set those limits for six chemicals out of 189. Chemical companies and lobbyists resisted federal regulation because they felt it was costly and a burden on business to change their behavior. David wanted to actually make it in their best interest to change their behavior. And if it couldn't happen on the federal level, then it would happen on the state level.
戴维即将获得实现这一目标的机会。第二年，即1986年，加州将举行州长选举。现任共和党州长在清理有毒化学品方面的记录非常糟糕，而民主党挑战者得到了塞拉俱乐部（Sierra Club）和经济民主运动（Campaign for Economic Democracy）等多个环境进步团体的支持。这些团体的领导人认为，如果他们能起草一项针对有毒化学品的投票倡议，并将其列入1986年的选票，他们就能动员更多倾向左翼的选民出来投票支持他们的民主党候选人。
And David was about to get the opportunity to do just that. The following year in 1986, there was going to be a big election for the governor of California. The incumbent Republican governor had a really bad record on toxic chemical cleanup, and the Democratic challenger was supported by a number of environmentally progressive groups like the Sierra Club and the Campaign for Economic Democracy. Leaders from these groups believed that they could sway more left-leaning voters to come out to the polls and vote for their Democratic candidate if they could write a ballot initiative addressing toxic chemicals and get it on the 1986 ballot.
所以他们需要有人来写它。而我当时算是房间里剩下的唯一一个人了。所以我基本上得自己写完整个东西。但通过投票倡议来通过法律有其自身的一系列挑战。编写投票倡议与在立法机构中编写法律不同。它必须通过。
So they needed somebody to write it. And I was sort of the only guy left in the room. So I essentially got to write the whole thing myself. But passing a law via ballot initiative came with its own set of challenges. Writing a ballot initiative is different from writing a law in a legislature. It has to pass.
它一旦通过就必须有效，但它首先必须能通过，这意味着它必须简单易懂，并且必须非常善于抵御棘手的负面论点。为了吸引选民，这项倡议必须走一条非常微妙的路线。它需要有强有力的环保信息，但也需要易于执行。它需要对有毒化学品采取强硬态度，但又不能强硬到成为加州企业的负担。这就是戴维提出《1986年安全饮用水和有毒物质强制执行法》（Safe Drinking Water and Toxic Enforcement Act of 1986），即“65号提案”的由来。
It has to work once it passes, but it also has to pass, which means it has to be pretty simple to explain, and it has to be pretty good at fending off tricky negative arguments. In order to appeal to voters, this initiative would have to walk a very fine line. It needed to have a strong environmental message, but also be simple to execute. It needed to be tough on toxic chemicals, but not so tough that it would be a burden on California businesses. Which is how David came up with the Safe Drinking Water and Toxic Enforcement Act of 1986, aka Proposition 65.
根据该法律的核心语言，65号提案将做一些新的、创新的，老实说有点软弱的事情。它说的是：如果你知道你正在让我接触到一种你知道会导致癌症的化学物质，你，企业，只要告诉我。这不会让任何人倒闭。但如果你要这样做，只要告诉我。该法律不会禁止有毒化学品。它不会限制接触有毒化学品。它甚至不会惩罚那些在产品中添加危险化学品的企业，
According to the core language of the law, Prop 65 would do something new and innovative and honestly kind of wimpy. What it said was, if you know you're exposing me, you business, if you know you're exposing me to a chemical that you know causes cancer, just tell me. Not putting anybody out of business. But if you're going to do that, just tell me. The law wouldn't ban toxic chemicals. It wouldn't limit exposure to toxic chemicals. It wouldn't even punish businesses for adding dangerous chemicals to their products
或者在供水系统中添加危险化学品。它只是说，在加利福尼亚州，如果产品含有导致癌症或出生缺陷的化学物质，就必须有“清晰且合理的警告”。该法律将广泛适用于加州的所有产品，而不是试图针对单一的化学物质。
or to the water system. It just said that in the state of California, if a product contained a chemical that caused cancer or birth defects, there had to be a quote, clear and reasonable warning. The law would broadly be applied to all products in California rather than trying to target individual chemicals.
它也适用于从州外任何地方向加州分销产品的企业，而不是试图针对单一的化学物质。其理念是，没有哪家理智的公司会愿意给自己贴上一个鲜红的警告标签，声称他们是在故意毒害你。所以这项法律会推动公司走向那个神奇的词：重新配方（Reformulation）。重新配方。
It also applied to businesses who distribute products in California, rather than trying to target individual chemicals. It also applied to businesses who distribute products into California from anywhere outside of the state. The idea was that no sane company would wanna brand itself with a scarlet warning label saying that they were intentionally poisoning you. So this law would nudge companies towards the magic word. Reformulation. Reformulation.
重新配方。如果一家公司知道它正在用危险成分制造某种东西，它就会重新配方以剔除该成分。如果不这样做，产品就需要贴上警告标签。而理想的警告数量是零。65号提案的竞选活动于1986年正式开始。老实说，即使是负责竞选活动的人，对法律通过也没抱太大希望。
Reformulation. If a company knew that it was making something with a dangerous ingredient, it would reformulate to leave out that ingredient. And if it didn't, the product would need a warning. And the ideal number of warnings is zero. The Proposition 65 campaign began in earnest in 1986. And to be honest, not even the people running the campaign had much hope of the law passing.
我的意思是，我们使用的口号是“对有毒物质采取强硬态度”，我认为最终这可能不是最好的口号。这是汤姆·爱泼斯坦（Tom Epstein），65号提案的竞选经理。他说，这项倡议面临着一些相当严峻的挑战。现任州长站出来反对这项法律，石油和化学公司以及许多企业和农业团体也加入了反对行列。随之而来的是大量资金支持“反对65号提案”的运动。我们只有大约一百万美元，而对手花了近五百万美元。但65号提案确实有几个有利条件。
The messaging, I mean, we used as our tagline get tough on toxics, which I think in the end probably wasn't the best tagline. This is Tom Epstein, the campaign manager for Prop 65. He says the initiative came up against some pretty looming odds. The incumbent governor came out in opposition to the law, along with oil and chemical companies and a number of businesses and agricultural groups. And along with that opposition came a lot of money supporting the no on 65 campaign. We only had about a million dollars in the opponent's spend, almost five million. But Prop 65 did have a couple things going for it.
第一，一个相当合理的环保信息。第二……准备好了。双脚与肩同宽站立。收腹。臀部内收。简·方达（Jane Fonda）。吸气，呼气。再来，吸气，呼气。
One, a pretty reasonable environmental message. And two... Let's get ready. Stand with your feet shoulder-width apart. Tummies are in. Hips tucked under. Jane Fonda. Inhale and exhale. Again, Inhale and exhale.
再来，抬起并呼气。女演员兼活动家简·方达和她当时的丈夫、州议员汤姆·海登（Tom Hayden）是经济民主运动的共同创始人。方达和海登都是竞选州长的民主党候选人的坚定支持者，并深度参与了65号提案的竞选活动。方达利用她的名人号召力，召集了一群名人参加竞选活动，以提高人们的意识并为65号提案筹集资金。这真的很有趣。
Again, lift and exhale. Actress and activist Jane Fonda and her husband at the time, State Assemblyman Tom Hayden, were co-founders of the campaign for Economic Democracy. Fonda and Hayden were both big supporters of the Democratic candidate running for governor and very involved with the Prop 65 campaign. Fonda used her celebrity poll to wrangle a group of famous people to hit the campaign trail to raise awareness and funds for Prop 65. It was really fun.
它有很多非常年轻的“黑帮”明星，也有简的老朋友。大约40位好莱坞人士，有些非常出名，有些只有你看电视剧时才认识，但确实是一群人。乌比·戈德堡（Whoopi Goldberg）、小艾德·贝格里（Ed Begley Jr.）、罗伯·劳（Rob Lowe）和切维·切斯（Chevy Chase）都支持这项倡议。这是迈克尔·J·福克斯（Michael J. Fox），在米高梅影城外的一场支持65号提案的派对上。
It had a lot of the really young kind of black pack stars but also older friends of Jane. About 40 Hollywood people, some very famous and some famous only if you watch TV series, but quite a collection of people. Whoopi Goldberg, Ed Bagley Jr., Rob Lowe, and Chevy Chase all got behind the initiative. Here's Michael J. Fox, outside of a yes on Proposition 65 party at MGM Studios.
我想我感兴趣的原因，就是任何人感兴趣的原因。它本质上是说，那些负责在污染我们饮用水的地区和情况下倾倒毒素、倾倒毒药的人，必须承担责任，承认这一点，告诉我们他们倾倒了什么，它是如何到达我们这里的，我认为这对我来说是一件很容易支持的事情。遗憾的是，简·方达无法接受这个故事的采访。
Why I'm interested, I think, is why anybody would be interested in it. It's essentially saying those responsible for dumping toxins, dumping poisons in areas and situations where it contaminates our drinking water have to live up to it, admit it, tell us what they're dumping, how it's getting to us, and I think that that's a real easy thing to support for me. Jane Fonda, unfortunately, was not available for an interview for this story.
好消息是我确实找到了她在一个支持65号提案活动上发言的片段。坏消息是它只有大约三秒长，而且她在喊着听起来像“软糖豆”（jelly bean）的词。软糖豆！呜！我不知道，我很抱歉。这群明星挤进了一支车队，他们称之为“清洁水
The good news is I did manage to track down a clip of her speaking at a yes on 65 event. The bad news is it's only about three seconds long, and she's shouting what sounds like the word jelly bean. Jelly bean! Woo! I don't know, I'm sorry. The star-studded group crammed into a fleet of buses which they called the Clean Water
大篷车”，开始了为期三天、途经九个城市的加州巡回之旅。作为竞选团队的一员，戴维·罗得以随名人车队旅行。有一次，我们开车经过中央谷地，被几名摩托车警察拦下了。据《洛杉矶时报》报道，罗伯·劳和达芙妮·祖尼加（Daphne Zuniga）打开了清洁水巴士顶部的紧急锁，在时速60英里的情况下挂在车顶上。警察拦下了车，领头的巴士停了下来，巴士司机被示意下车。于是巴士司机出来和摩托车警察交谈，简·方达出来了，
Caravan and embarked on a three-day, nine-city tour up and down California. As a member of the campaign, David Rowe got to travel with the celebrity caravan. At one point, we were driving in the Central valley and were pulled over by a couple of motorcycle cops. According to the LA Times, Rob Lowe and Daphne Zuniga popped open the emergency latch at the top of the clean water bus and were hanging out the roof at 60 miles per hour. And so the cop stops, the lead bus pulls him over and the bus driver is signal to get out. So the bus driver comes out to talk to the motorcycle cop and out comes Jane Fonda,
还有切维·切斯、摩根·费尔柴尔德（Morgan Fairchild）以及所有这些人。警察完全惊呆了。这太搞笑了，因为当时就是，“哦”。你们拿到罚单了吗？我们没有拿到罚单。像这样的标志正在加州的数千家企业中竖起，警告说在场所的某个地方存在可能导致癌症或出生缺陷的化学物质。这些新的警告标志是1986年投票倡议的结果。
and Chevy Chase, and Morgan Fairchild, and all these people. And the cop just completely loses it. And it was hysterical because it was just, oh. Did you get a ticket? We did not get a ticket. Signs like this are going up at thousands of businesses in California, warning that somewhere on the premises there are chemicals which could cause cancer or birth defects. The new warning signs are the result of a 1986 ballot initiative.
65号提案以压倒性优势通过了加州选民的投票。凭借一些令人印象深刻的名人背书和明确的环保信息，65号提案取得了压倒性的胜利。这是自1972年《海岸法》（Coastal Act）以来，加州通过的第一项环境投票措施。所以已经过去了14年。在65号提案的实际文本中，法律起草者从未真正定义过什么是“清晰且合理的警告”。所以戴维·罗说，当法律真正生效时，许多企业试图通过故意含糊其辞来规避这一技术细节。试图通过故意含糊其辞来规避这一技术细节。
Proposition 65 passed overwhelmingly by California voters. Armed with some impressive celebrity endorsements and a clear environmental message, Proposition 65 passed in a landslide victory. It was the first environmental ballot measure to pass in California since the Coastal Act of 1972. So it had been 14 years. In the actual language of Prop 65, the drafters of the law never actually defined what a clear and reasonable warning meant. So David Rowe says that when the law actually went into effect, many businesses tried to weasel around this technicality by being purposely opaque about warnings. trying to weasel around this technicality by being purposely opaque about warnings.
他们这样做的方法是设立一个800电话，并在杂货店、五金店等地方的前面竖起一个标志。在早期，一个名为“成分沟通委员会”（Ingredient Communication Council）的亲商业团体成立，旨在帮助公司策划规避65号提案的法规。他们没有建议企业警告顾客产品中的化学物质暴露，
And the way they did that was to set up an 800 number and put a sign in front of grocery stores and hardware stores and things like that. In the early days, a pro-business group called the Ingredient Communication Council was created to help companies scheme around Prop 65 regulations. Instead of advising businesses to warn customers about chemical exposure in their products,
而是在杂货店等地方外面挂上了通用的警告标志。这些标志基本上写着：“嘿，伙计们，加州有项法律规定我们必须警告你们关于致癌化学物质的事，如果你想了解更多，请拨打这个800电话。”如果消费者拨打了那个800电话，他们会被转接到内布拉斯加州奥马哈市的一个呼叫中心。电话那头的人会说：“嗯，你是说大罐装还是小罐装？”
they hung up generic warning signs outside of places like grocery stores. Those signs basically said, hey guys, there's this law in California that says we have to warn you about cancer causing chemicals and if you want to learn more about that, call this 800 number. If a consumer called that 800 number, they would be directed to a call center in Omaha, Nebraska. The person at the other end of the phone would say, well, do you mean the large size can or the small can?
“你是说水煮豌豆还是奶油酱豌豆？你是说这家公司的品牌还是那家公司的品牌？”如果你完成了这20个问题，他们会按下一个按钮，给你播放一段录制的警告。这很快被认定为非法。但这种关于什么是“清晰且合理的警告”的早期混乱确实做了一件事。它创造了一个非常强烈的动机，让企业进来乞求监管。
Do you mean the peas in water or the peas with cream sauce? Do you mean the brand by this company or the brand by that company? If you got to the end of the 20 questions, they'd push a button and give you a recorded warning. This was quickly determined to be illegal. But this early confusion of what constituted a clear and reasonable warning did do one thing. It created a very strong incentive for businesses to go in and beg for regulation.
“告诉我们什么能让我们摆脱困境。”州政府很早就制定了一个措辞公式。那个由加州环境健康危害评估办公室（Office of Environmental Health Hazard Assessment）确定的措辞公式是：“警告：本产品含有加利福尼亚州已知会导致癌症和出生缺陷或其他生殖危害的化学物质。”从那时起，环保倡导者充分利用了65号提案。第一个提交的65号提案诉讼是由一位民主党参议院候选人发起的，他利用该法律针对被指控污染加州地下水的石油公司。
Tell us what will get us off the hook. And there's a formula of words that the state came up with early on. That formula of words determined by the California Office of Environmental Health Hazard Assessment was warning. This product contains chemicals known to the state of California to cause cancer and birth defects or other reproductive harm. From there on out, environmental advocates put Prop 65 to good use. The very first Prop 65 action filed was by a Democratic Senate candidate who used the law to target oil companies accused of polluting California's groundwater.
为了避免警告标签，许多大公司做了65号提案的设计者们所预期的事。许多公司，包括可口可乐和吉列，都进行了重新配方以避免警告标签。呃，罗曼，你忘了那个……哦，对了，重新配方。过去有一种液体叫“修正液”（White Out）。你年纪够大记得这个吗？当然记得。修正液里有一种有毒化学物质。65号提案通过后，他们改变了配方以消除那种有毒化学物质，你知道，人们会用手触摸它，吸入它之类的。所以这就是初衷，如果他们被迫在化妆品之类的东西上贴上警告，他们就会停止这样做。
And in order to avoid a warning label, a lot of big companies did exactly what the architects of Prop 65 intended. Lots of companies, including Coca-Cola and Gillette, reformulated to avoid the warning label. Uh, Roman, you forgot the uh... Oh right, reformulated. Back in the day, there was this liquid called White Out. Are you old enough to remember this? And how? Whiteout had a toxic chemical in it. And after Prop 65 passed, they changed the formulation to eliminate that toxic chemical, which, you know, people were touching with their hands and breathing in and stuff like that. So that was the idea, that if they were forced to put a warning on in cosmetics and stuff like that, they would stop doing it.
在理想世界中，这就是65号提案的运作方式。危险化学物质将从产品中剔除，任何东西上都没有警告标签，故事结束。但在现实中，情况要混乱得多。主要是因为违反65号提案的人不会面临刑事处罚。他们面临的是诉讼……他们面临诉讼。很多诉讼。
In an ideal world, this is how Proposition 65 would work. Dangerous chemicals would be taken out of products and no warning labels on anything, end of story. But in reality, it's been a lot messier than that. Mostly because people who violate Prop 65 don't face criminal penalties. They face lawsuits.. They face lawsuits. A lot of lawsuits.
我们没有预料到会发展出这种围绕起诉每个人的法律产业。总检察长是主要的检察官，但65号提案规定，任何以公共利益为目的的私人个人都可以对任何在没有适当警告的情况下让消费者接触有毒化学物质的公司提起诉讼。这意味着它基本上是由每个人来执行的。
We didn't anticipate that this, you know, legal industry would develop around suing everybody. The attorney general is the principal prosecutor, but Prop 65 states that any private individual acting in the public interest can file a lawsuit against any company exposing consumers to toxic chemicals without properly warning them. And that means it is essentially enforced by everyone.
地方检察官、总检察长和城市检察官的常规执法根本无法覆盖所有领域。环境问题在太多地方出现了。所以让我们招募公民执法。这是一种确保更多事情得到覆盖的方法。因此，如果一个产品上没有警告标签，任何私人个人都可以自己测试该产品。如果他们发现有毒化学物质的含量很高，
Regular enforcement by district attorneys and attorneys general and city attorneys couldn't possibly cover the waterfront. Environmental problems just pop up in too many places. So let's enlist citizen enforcement. That's a way to make sure that more things get covered. So if a product doesn't have a warning label on it, any private individual can test that product for themselves. And if they find a significant level of a toxic chemical,
他们就可以对该企业提起诉讼。如果该个人胜诉，他们可以收取罚款，被告必须支付。被起诉的企业有责任证明其产品低于65号提案的限值。如果他们做不到，他们就有责任支付每天每项违规行为最高2500美元的罚款，这可能是一大笔钱。我们谈论的这些和解金额在五位数或六位数，对于一家新兴和成长中的企业来说，这是一大笔钱，特别是如果你不在加州，特别是如果你的利润率很低，特别是如果你已经投入了
they can file a lawsuit against that business. If that individual wins, they get to collect a penalty fee, which the defendant has to pay. It's the responsibility of the business being sued to prove their product is under the Prop 65 limit. And if they can't, they're liable to pay up to $2,500 per violation per day, which could be a lot of money. These settlements that we're talking about are in the five or six figures, which is a lot of money for an up and coming and growing business, especially if you're not based in California, especially if your profit margins are low, especially if you've invested your
毕生积蓄来开发这个品牌。这是鲍沃（Baovoo），旧金山Stoll Reves律师事务所的合伙人，负责该事务所的65号提案业务。你知道，我有一些客户在代理过程中破产了。65号提案的私人执法要素一直是环保人士的有力工具，但它也激励了更多的诉讼，这是一个问题，因为并非每个违反法律的人都是那种必须被消灭的“地球超人”反派。今天，65号提案名单上有超过1000种化学物质，请不要惊慌，但我们吃、买和接触的很多垃圾中都有不同数量
life savings in developing this brand. This is Baovoo, a partner at Stoll Reves in San Francisco who heads up the firm's Proposition 65 practice. You know, I've had some clients that during the course of the representation go bankrupt. The private enforcement element of Prop 65 has been a powerful tool for environmentalists, but it's also incentivized more lawsuits, which is an issue because not everyone who violates the law is a must-tortling Captain Planet villain. Today there are over 1,000 chemicals on the Proposition 65 list and please don't freak out, but there are varying amounts
的这些化学物质。对于一些企业，尤其是小型企业来说，测试所有1000种化学物质可能既困难又昂贵。我已经做了十多年了。这就是我日复一日所做的事情。有时仍然很难得出一个关于是否需要警告的明确的“是”或“否”的答案。如果这是我的饭碗，小企业又该如何驾驭这项法律呢？根据2019年的一项研究，65号提案的诉讼每年让加州企业损失约3000万美元。
of these chemicals in a lot of the crap that we eat, buy, and are exposed to. For some businesses, especially smaller ones, it could be difficult and expensive to test for all 1,000 chemicals. I've done this for over a decade. This is why I do day in and day out. It's still hard sometimes to come up with a crystal clear yes or no answer about whether or not a warning is needed. And if this is my bread and butter, how can a small business navigate that law? According to one 2019 study, Prop 65 lawsuits were costing California businesses around $30 million a year.
而这3000万美元中的76%直接进了律师的口袋。这项法律是由“赏金猎人”和与他们合作的律师执行的。妮可·克里姆（Nicole Krim）是Diso USA的产品监管合规和贸易经理。如果你没听说过，Diso有点像日本版的“一元店”，但东西更可爱。妮可的工作是确保所有Diso产品符合联邦、州和地方法规。她最大的不满之一是那些通常被称为“赏金猎人”的原告类型。这些是寻求简单和解以收取罚款的连环原告。
And 76% of that $30 million went straight to attorney's fees. This law is enforced by bounty hunters and the lawyers that they work with. Nicole Krim is the Product Regulatory Compliance and Trade Manager at Diso USA. If you've never heard of it, Diso is sort of like a Japanese equivalent to the dollar store but with cuter stuff. Nicole's job is to make sure all Diso products meet federal, state, and local regulations. And one of her biggest beefs is with the type of plaintiffs commonly referred to as bounty hunters. These are the serial plaintiffs that seek out easy settlements to collect penalty fees.
你会遇到那些把你的公司当作个人银行的赏金猎人。他们会来。他们会买几样东西。他们会去测试这些东西。如果他们没发现什么，他们会回来，买更多，然后因为几样东西起诉你。然后你和解。然后他们又回来，因为另外几样东西起诉你。一旦你和解，他们又回来，因为更多东西起诉你。
You get bounty hunters that just treat your company like their own personal bank. They will come. They will buy a handful of items. They'll go test those items. If they don't see something, they'll come back, they'll buy more, and then they'll see you for a handful. And then you settle. And then they come back around, they'll see you for a couple more. And then as soon as you settle, they come back around and they see you for a few more.
有时这些原告是个人，有时他们是倡导团体，有时他们是“所谓的”倡导团体。所以看起来他们唯一做的事情就是起诉公司要钱。而且他们似乎并没有把这些钱用于加州人民的利益。我在研究这些倡导团体时掉进了一个兔子洞。他们中的许多人有听起来像伪环保的名字，而且网站上有完全相同的玛格丽特·米德（Margaret Mead）的名言。我非常努力地想与其中一个团体交谈，询问他们的
Sometimes these plaintiffs are individuals, sometimes they are advocacy groups, and sometimes they are advocacy groups, and sometimes they are finger quote advocacy groups. So it seems like the sole thing that they do is they sue companies for money. And then they don't seem to do anything with the money for the good of the people of California. I fell down a rabbit hole researching these advocacy groups. A lot of them have pseudo environmental sounding names and the same exact Margaret Mead quote on their website. I tried very hard to speak with one of these groups to ask where the money goes from their
和解金去了哪里，但这些人比简·方达还难联系。还有人担心这些连环原告在针对谁。我有客户和潜在客户联系我说，他们觉得最近很多亚洲品牌成了目标。65号提案的年度会议一直在争论“过度警告”的问题。可怜的亚洲零食制造商。这已经引起了关注，因为一些想赚钱的律师起诉了其中一些。
settlements, but these people are harder to get in touch with than Jane Fonda. And then there are concerns over who these serial plaintiffs are coming after. I have had clients and potential clients reach out to me and say that they feel a lot of Asian brands are recently being targeted. Proposition 65 annual conference debates about overwarning all the time. Pity the poor maker of Asian snacks. This is something that's gotten, seriously, this has gotten attention because some lawyers trying to make money have sued some of those.
在65号提案圈子里私下议论的一件事是，有多少亚洲企业被诉讼缠身。你可以在总检察长网站上的65号提案违规通知数量中看到这一点，但如果你走进加州的任何一家亚洲超市，这一点也非常明显。整个超市货架上都贴满了65号提案的警告标签。就在我写这句话的时候，我停下手头的工作去翻我的储藏室。我至少找出了11种贴有65号提案警告的亚洲食品。
Something that's been whispered about inside of Prop 65 circles is the number of Asian businesses who have been slapped with lawsuits. You can see this in the number of Prop 65 violation notices on the Attorney General's website, but it's also very apparent if you've ever stepped inside an Asian supermarket in California. There are Proposition 65 warning labels lining entire supermarket shelves. While I was in the middle of writing this very sentence, I stopped what I was doing to dig through my own pantry. I pulled out at least 11 different Asian food products with a Proposition 65 warning
这有几个可能的原因。许多这些企业销售从化学法规不同的国家进口的商品。另一个原因是，其中一些企业规模较小，负担不起漫长的诉讼过程，因此他们更有可能和解。我无法解释他们这样做的动机，但我会说，当这些公司面临诉讼时，往往很难驾驭65号提案。你知道，很多时候你去亚洲市场，因为我自己也是亚洲人，因为产品很便宜。
on them. There are a few possible reasons for this. A lot of these businesses sell goods imported from countries with different chemical regulations. Another reason is that some of these businesses are smaller and can't afford a lengthy litigation process, so they are more likely to settle. I can't explain their motivations for that, but I will say that it's often hard for those companies to navigate Proposition 65 when they're faced with a suit. You know, a lot of times you go to Asian markets being Asian myself because the products are cheap.
所以当你收到一份要求五位数或六位数赔偿的违规通知时，夫妻店真的很难支付。我不希望接触任何有毒化学物质，但这确实让你怀疑，这些产品贴上标签是因为它们有威胁，还是因为制造商和分销商是容易下手的目标。诉讼数量已经变成了一场如此艰难的战斗，以至于许多企业只是选择了更简单的路线，以求自保。我们现在看到的是，鉴于为65号提案案件辩护的挑战，我们看到产品上出现了大量的过度警告。
And so when you're hit with a notice of violation demanding, you know, five or six figures, it's really hard for a bomb and pop company to pay for that. I don't want any exposure to toxic chemicals, but it does make you wonder if these products have a label on them because they're a threat or because the manufacturers and distributors were an easy target. The amount of lawsuits has become such an uphill battle that many businesses just take the easier route and cover their bases. What we see nowadays is given the challenges to defending a Proposition 65 case, we're seeing a lot of over-warning on products.
流行的笑话是：“哦，在加利福尼亚州，你什么东西都能得癌症。”65号提案的批评者将其描述为一项初衷良好的环境法，却造成了不必要的附带损害。即使是那些支持65号提案的人也承认，作为一个警告系统，这些标签有很多缺陷。
The running joke is, oh, in the state of California, you can get cancer from everything. Critics of Prop 65 describe it as a well-intentioned environmental law that has caused unnecessary collateral damage. Even those who support Proposition 65 admit that as a warning system, these labels have a lot of flaws.
但艾伦·赫什（Alan Hirsch），加州环境健康危害评估办公室（监管65号提案的机构）的前首席副主任说，尽管有这些缺陷，这些标签的目的远不止是警告我们。我们每天承受的所有暴露加在一起，它们增加了我们每个人面临的癌症风险。而且……它们增加了癌症风险，这就是我们刚才谈到的，互动。
But Alan Hirsch, the former Chief Deputy Director of the California Office of Environmental Health Hazard Assessment, which is the agency that regulates Prop 65, says that despite those flaws, the labels serve a purpose far beyond just warning us. All the exposures that we incur every day add up, they contribute to the risk of cancer that we all face. And... They contribute to the risk of cancer, that was where we were, interactive.
好的。但这是一个很棒的音效。你看，我应该在背景中有警笛声的情况下说话，这太完美了。在艾伦·赫什被另一个散弹枪式的警告系统打断之前，他告诉我，即使它们过度饱和，在表面层面上，65号提案的标签
Okay. But this is the great sound effect. You see, I should be talking with a siren in the background, it's perfect. Before Alan Hirsch was interrupted by yet another scatter shot warning system, he was telling me that even if they are oversaturated, on a surface level, Prop 65 labels
可以帮助消费者就他们的健康做出明智的决定。警告是一个提醒，你可能需要考虑是否要购买这个产品。如果你想买，没问题。这是你的权利。这只是一次暴露。它不一定是一件改变生活的事情。但如果你，再次强调，想尝试管理那种累积风险，警告是你用来做到这一点的一条信息。
can help consumers make informed decisions about their health. The warning is one heads up that you may want to think about whether you want to buy this product. If you do, fine. It's your right to do it. This is one exposure. It's not necessarily a life-changing thing. But if you, again, you want to try to manage that cumulative risk, the warnings are one piece of information that you can use to do that.
在更深层次上，赫什想强调，那些无处不在的警告标志只是一个实际上正在运作的隐藏系统中最显眼的部分。多年来已经进行了无数次的重新配方，其中许多老实说我们知之甚少，因为企业是在悄悄地做。他们不会宣布。但我们多次从商业游说者那里听到：“天哪，当你们列出一种化学物质时，你无法相信它在企业中产生了多少活动。”“这是什么化学物质？我们在用它吗？我们如何把它从产品中剔除？”
And on a deeper level, Hirsch wants to emphasize that those ubiquitous warning signs are just the most conspicuous part of a hidden system that's actually working. There have been any number of reformulations over the years, many of which honestly, we don't know that much about because businesses do it quietly. They don't announce it. But we have heard many times from business lobbyists, boy, when you guys list a chemical, you wouldn't believe how much activity, you know, it generates among businesses. What's this chemical? Are we using it? How do we get it out of the product?
“我们能做到吗？”我认为，通过这些警告，它推动了市场做得更好。他们可以做得更好。这是托德·库伯曼（Todd Cooberman）。他是研究员兼ConsumerLab.com的总裁，该公司提供独立的产品测试。他实际上并不认为标签本身在传达危险方面做得很好，但他表示，这不一定
Can we do that? By having these warnings, I think it drives the market to do better. They can do better. This is Todd Cooberman. He's a researcher and president of ConsumerLab.com, which provides independent product testing. He actually doesn't think the labels themselves are great at communicating danger, but he says it's not necessarily
是标签在保护加州人。65号提案确实是目前唯一的州法律，在很多方面，它确实是全国唯一对产品中可以有多少污染（至少在没有警告标签的情况下）有限制的法律。FDA确实有一些产品不应该销售的限值，但在大多数产品的限值方面，它确实远远落后于65号提案。我们经常不得不看看其他国家。
the labels protecting Californians. The Prop 65 law is really the only state law out there and really it's the only law in the country in many regards for a limit on how much contamination there can be in a product, at least without a warning label. The FDA does have some limits where products just shouldn't be sold, but it's really far behind Prop 65 in terms of limits on most products. We often have to look at other countries.
加拿大在设定限值方面肯定领先于美国。这一轮你赢了，加拿大。加州非常独特，你知道，向你们州设定这些限值致敬。当我和戴维·罗交谈时，他指出了65号提案刚通过时的一个惊人例子。它涉及铅的含量，这是一种在任何水平下都危险的物质，被允许存在于输送我们饮用水的管道中。根据联邦法律，“无铅”被定义为含铅量8%。
Canada is certainly head of the US in terms of setting limits. You win this round, Canada. California is very unique, you know, and hats off to your state for setting these limits. When I was talking with David Rowe, he pointed out a striking example from around the time when Prop 65 was first passed. It involved the amount of lead, a substance dangerous at any level, that was allowed to be in the pipes that carried our drinking water. Lead-free under federal law was defined as 8% lead.
任何低于8%铅含量的东西在官方和法律上都被称为“无铅”。这只是为了向你展示联邦法律中理论与实践之间的差距，因为显然那是被游说出来的，那个规定“无铅等于少于8%”的特定法规，是一场游说的胜利，进入了一项本应将铅排除在外的法律中。65号提案能够作为一种保障措施来弥补联邦法规中的这些空白，鼓励公司自我监管。令人惊叹的是，有多少东西，以及多么广泛的东西，似乎已经穿过了联邦的安全网，并被65号提案的后盾所捕获。戴维实际上拿出了所有这些东西的清单。
Anything less than 8% lead was officially, legally, quote, led free. And it's just to show you the gap between theory and practice in federal law, because obviously that was lobbied to that particular regulation that said led free equals less than 8% was a triumph of lobbying into a law that was supposed to keep lead out of things. Prop 65 was able to act as a safeguard to those gaps in federal regulations by encouraging companies to regulate themselves. And it's remarkable how many things and what an incredible range of things seem to have gotten through that federal safety net and have been caught by the backstop of Prop 65. David actually whipped out a list of all of these things.
黄铜水龙头、盘子、瓷盘、钙补充剂、水表、镀锌管、水晶醒酒器、酒瓶上的箔盖、黄铜钥匙、手动工具、运动重量、雨衣、电工胶带、电线、自行车锁、婴儿皮疹粉、止泻药、染发剂、鼻喷雾剂、去污剂。我甚至不会继续列举了。这些都是专门去除了铅的东西。值得注意的是，联邦对“无铅”的定义最终从8%降低到了0.25%。但这一变化直到2011年才发生。当公司为了符合65号提案的指导方针而去除危险化学物质时，不仅仅是加州人
Brass faucets, dishes, china dishes, calcium supplements, water meters, galvanized pipe, crystal decanters, foil caps on wine bottles, brass keys, hand tools, exercise weights, raincoats, electrical tape, electrical cords, bicycle locks, baby rash powders, anti-diarrhea medicines, hair dyes, nasal sprays, spot remover. I won't even keep going. Those are all things that lead specifically was taken out of. It's important to note that the federal definition of lead-free was eventually lowered from 8% to 0.25%. But that change didn't take place until 2011. When companies remove dangerous chemicals to meet Prop 65 guidelines, it's not just Californians
从中受益。同样的产品也为全国其他地区制造得更安全。而且由于加州拥有世界第五大经济体，全球的生产者也被迫这样做。这只是对世界的一点点调整，对大多数人来说是隐形的。没有人真正知道它正在发生，但它正在对人们在日常生活中接触到多少有毒化学物质以及在多少种情况下接触到它们产生巨大的影响，这当然就是重点。我问了这个故事的每个人，如果他们能改变65号提案的任何东西，那会
who benefit from that. The same products are made safer for the rest of the country as well. And because the state of California has the fifth biggest economy in the world, producers globally are pushed to do the same. That's just a little adjustment to the world that's invisible to most people. Nobody really knows it's happening, but is making a big difference in how many toxic chemicals and how many contexts people are getting exposed to in their daily lives, which is, of course, the point. I asked everyone for this story if they could change anything about Prop 65, what would
是什么？鲍沃说他希望让法律对企业来说更容易驾驭。托德·库伯曼希望警告标签本身对消费者更有帮助。艾伦·赫什希望让提起轻率诉讼变得更难一些。而戴维·罗呢？
it be? Balvu said that he would want to make the law easier to navigate for businesses. Todd Cooperman would want the warning labels themselves to be more helpful to consumers. Alan Hirsch wants it to be a little harder to bring about frivolous lawsuits. And David Rowe?
正如你可以想象的那样，我每年在年度会议上都会被问到这个问题。当然，有人要么想有一个“顿悟时刻”，要么想让我对最初的起草感到非常自豪。我尽量避免两者。但我意识到，“我们应该如何改变65号提案”根本不是应该问的问题。我们实际上应该问的是，
I get this question every year at the annual conference, as you can imagine. And of course, somebody wants to either have an aha moment or make me look extremely proud of the original drafting. I try to avoid both. I realized though that how should we change Prop 65 wasn't the right question to be asking at all. What we should be actually asking is,
联邦政府如何能做更多的事情来保护我们，这样我们就不再需要65号提案了？因为尽管它不完美，尽管它带来了所有的头痛、挫折和混乱，但65号提案算是我们所能拥有的最好的东西了。现在，当我看到那个贴在我那漂亮的新公寓楼前面的65号提案标签时，我绝对不会再把它当作耳旁风了。那个标志提醒我，我正在见证一个正在失败的系统，因为如果它奏效了，
how can the federal government do more to protect us so that we don't need Prop 65 anymore? Because imperfect as it is, and for all of the headaches, frustrations, and confusion it has caused, Prop 65 is kind of the best thing we've got. Now, when I see that Prop 65 label stuck to the front of my fancy new apartment building, I definitely don't brush it off anymore. That sign is a reminder that I'm witnessing a system that's failing, because if it worked,
联邦政府该如何采取更多措施来保护我们，从而让我们不再需要65号提案？因为尽管它并不完美，且带来了种种麻烦、挫折和困惑，但65号提案在某种程度上已经是我们所能拥有的最好方案了。现在，当我看到贴在我那栋高档新公寓楼前的65号提案标签时，我绝对不会再视而不见。那个标志提醒我，我正在见证一个正在失效的系统，因为如果它真的有效的话，
then there wouldn't be a warning label at all. But on the other hand, at least I know there's some sort of system in place trying to keep us all safe. Which I wish I could say felt more comforting. So could I, I was wondering if I could help, if you could help me navigate something. Todd Cooperman does product testing and analysis, so I figured if anyone could help me figure out the sign on my apartment building, it would be him. It says, uh, warning, entering this area can expose you to chemicals known to the state of
那根本就不会有警告标签。但另一方面，至少我知道有一个系统在试图保护我们所有人的安全。我真希望我能说这让人感到更安心。我也一样，我在想我能不能寻求帮助，如果你能帮我理清一些事情。托德·库珀曼（Todd Cooperman）从事产品测试和分析，所以我认为如果有人能帮我弄清楚我公寓楼上的标志，那一定是他。上面写着，呃，警告，进入该区域可能会使您接触到加利福尼亚州已知会导致癌症和出生缺陷或其他生殖危害的化学物质，包括苯（一种用于小便池清洁剂的化学物质）和甲苯（一种用于常见家用清洁产品的化学物质）。
California to cause cancer and birth defects or other reproductive harm, including benzene, a chemical used in urinal cleaners, and toluene, a chemical used in common household cleaning products. Like me as a resident of the building, what's the best way for me to calculate that risk for myself? I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. Yeah, I'm on my own for that one. After the break we... Ugh, again? Okay, we'll wait for this to pass. Okay.
作为这栋楼的住户，我该如何为自己计算这种风险呢？我不知道。是的，我不知道。是的，这件事我只能靠自己了。休息之后我们……呃，又来了？好吧，我们等它过去。好的。
After the break, we revisit another story about excessive alarms. Stay with us. We first ran this next story that you're about to hear back in 2018 as part of our year-end mini-stories. It was the first story that Vivian Lay reported for us. Coincidentally, it was also about excessive alarms. And if you listen really closely, you can hear how nervous she is. So I want to start with the worst nuclear accident
休息之后，我们将重温另一个关于警报过多的故事。请继续收听。我们第一次播出接下来要听的这个故事是在2018年，作为我们年终迷你故事的一部分。这是薇薇安·雷（Vivian Lay）为我们报道的第一个故事。巧合的是，它也是关于警报过多的。如果你仔细听，你能听出她有多紧张。所以我想从美国历史上最严重的核事故开始讲起。
in US history. Goodness, okay, go ahead. For many years, there has been a vigorous debate in this country about the safety of the nation's 72 nuclear energy power plants. That debate is likely to be intensified because of what happened early this morning at a nuclear power plant in Pennsylvania. So you probably heard about this before because of this big news, but back in 1979 there was
天哪，好吧，请继续。多年来，关于美国72座核能发电厂的安全性，这个国家一直存在激烈的争论。由于今天清晨在宾夕法尼亚州一家核电站发生的事情，这种争论可能会加剧。所以你可能因为这个大新闻之前听说过这件事，但在1979年，三哩岛核电站发生了部分堆芯熔毁事故。
a partial core meltdown at the Three Mile Island nuclear power plant near Harrisburg, Pennsylvania. A cooling pump broke down and the plant did just what it was supposed to do. Shut it's all off. But not before some radioactivity had escaped. A bunch of communities around the reactor ended up having to evacuate and it just freaked a lot of people out. Well, they should have been freaked out.
地点在宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡附近。一个冷却泵坏了，电站的表现正如它应该做的那样。把一切都关掉。但在那之前，已经有一些放射性物质泄漏了。反应堆周围的一大群社区最终不得不撤离，这让很多人感到恐慌。嗯，他们确实应该感到恐慌。
That was freaking scary. So in the aftermath of what happened, the president ordered a commission to investigate what happened and there was this big post-mortem report to try to understand what had gone wrong. And what actually did go wrong? Well, it was kind of complicated because a lot of things went wrong. But Three Mile Island was a classic cascading failure type accident. So essentially, a relief valve in one of the react units got stuck in the open position, which caused all the
那真是太可怕了。因此，在事件发生后，总统下令成立一个委员会来调查发生了什么，并有一份大型的尸检报告试图了解出了什么问题。到底出了什么问题？嗯，这有点复杂，因为很多事情都出了问题。但三哩岛是一个典型的级联故障型事故。本质上，其中一个反应堆单元的泄压阀卡在了打开位置，导致所有的
coolant to be released. So the coolant ran out of the core and it started to overheat. And in the end, it ended up being a pretty minor mechanical breakdown. But what they found out was that it was actually human error that made the whole situation worse. Humans make everything worse. They really do. They really do. A cascading failure of humans.
冷却剂被释放。所以冷却剂从堆芯中流出，开始过热。最终，这演变成了一个相当小的机械故障。但他们发现，实际上是人为错误使整个情况变得更糟。人类让一切变得更糟。他们确实如此。他们确实如此。人类的级联故障。
But, you know, the plant operators could see and they could hear that something was wrong because all these lights are flashing and alarms are sounding, but it wasn't clear exactly what was wrong because all the alarms were really confusing and just made the situation worse. Because they went off all at the same time, that would have hindered communication at the very time when they needed to communicate. And who is that? So that's Judy Edwards. She studies psychoacoustics and alarm design at the University of Plymouth. And she told me that Three Mile Island is actually a really common case study when it comes to bad and ineffective alarm design.
但是，你知道，电站操作员可以看到也能听到出了问题，因为所有的灯都在闪烁，警报也在响，但并不清楚到底出了什么问题，因为所有的警报都非常令人困惑，反而让情况变得更糟。因为它们同时响起，这会在他们最需要沟通的时候阻碍沟通。那是谁？那是朱迪·爱德华兹（Judy Edwards）。她在普利茅斯大学研究心理声学和警报设计。她告诉我，三哩岛实际上是一个关于糟糕且无效的警报设计的非常典型的案例研究。
Three Mile Island is very well known for having hundreds of alarms going off in a very short period of time. Now that's an example where there was no alarm philosophy because that shouldn't have happened. So alarm design really matters. Yes, it definitely matters. And there have actually been other major accidents where alarms that were supposed to help people respond to emergency, but instead they made the situation worse.
三哩岛以在极短时间内响起数百个警报而闻名。这是一个没有警报理念的例子，因为那本不应该发生。所以警报设计真的很重要。是的，它绝对很重要。事实上，还有其他重大事故，本应帮助人们应对紧急情况的警报，反而使情况变得更糟。
Like the Deepwater Horizon accident in 2010, which caused a ton of oil to spill into the Gulf of Mexico. I didn't know that had anything to do with alarm failure. Oh yeah, yeah. It turned out that a bunch of the alarm systems on the Deepwater Rig had actually been inhibited for at least a year before the accidents happened because TransOcean, which is the company that ran the rig, didn't want false alarms to wake up the crew while they were sleeping.
比如2010年的深水地平线事故，导致大量石油泄漏到墨西哥湾。我不知道这和警报故障有什么关系。哦，是的，是的。事实证明，深水地平线钻井平台上的许多警报系统在事故发生前至少一年就已经被禁用了，因为运营该平台的公司TransOcean不想让假警报在船员睡觉时吵醒他们。
So the alarms were too easily triggered and so they just turned them off so they didn't upset the operation of the rig. Yeah, exactly, false alarm syndrome basically. So this is the kind of stuff that Professor Edwardi thinks about a lot. Yes, yeah, she thinks about the best ways to design alarms
所以警报太容易被触发了，于是他们就把它们关掉了，这样就不会干扰钻井平台的运行。是的，没错，基本上就是假警报综合症。所以这就是爱德华兹教授经常思考的事情。是的，是的，她思考的是设计警报的最佳方式，
so that they can accomplish what they need to do. And one of her big concerns is that humans are just bombarded by so many alarms in our everyday life that we just start tuning them out. Or turning them off. Yeah. Because I think the whole world suffers from alarm fatigue. Because I think we're just so used to alarms
以便它们能够完成它们需要做的事情。她的一大担忧是，人类在日常生活中被太多的警报轰炸，以至于我们开始忽略它们。或者把它们关掉。是的。因为我认为全世界都患有警报疲劳。因为我认为我们已经习惯了警报
just going off all the time. And they're almost, they're just a backdrop to our lives. She says that the average person probably hears about 100 different types of alarms a day. They're just all the time, you stand at the cash register and it's beeping away and it's, and then you hear cars, car alarms going off and you've got microwaves and you've got to, everything beeps. And for no good reason, quite a lot of the time. And so people just start tuning them out
一直响个不停。它们几乎成了我们生活的背景。她说普通人每天可能会听到大约100种不同类型的警报。它们一直都在响，你站在收银台前，它在发出哔哔声，然后你听到汽车警报声，还有微波炉，一切都在响。而且很多时候毫无理由。所以人们就开始忽略它们，
and they lose track of which alarms are important and which ones aren't. If everything in the world is beeping, we kind of forget that those beeps are trying to point out actual problems. But another consideration is that alarm tones themselves should communicate something about what the problem is. And so how does that work?
并且忘记了哪些警报是重要的，哪些不是。如果世界上的一切都在发出哔哔声，我们就会忘记这些哔哔声是在试图指出实际的问题。但另一个考虑因素是，警报音本身应该传达关于问题所在的信息。那么这是如何运作的呢？
Okay, so when you think of an alarm sound, what do you think of? Well, I think of a bracing, klaxon, beeping, siren, high-pitched, shrill, alarming, alarming, upsetting. Yes, yes, exactly. So we basically all have like one cultural reference point for what an alarm should sound like. And that's because like in the olden days, we didn't really have much range in terms of alarm mechanisms. In the past, alarms, you could only make an alarm by either pushing sand, pushing air through an object like a klaxon, or by hitting something like a bell.
好的，当你想到警报声时，你会想到什么？嗯，我想到了刺耳的、喇叭声、哔哔声、警笛声、高音、尖锐、令人惊恐、令人不安。是的，是的，完全正确。所以我们基本上都有一个关于警报应该听起来像什么的文化参考点。这是因为在过去，我们在警报机制方面并没有太多的选择。在过去，警报，你只能通过推动空气穿过物体（如喇叭）或者敲击物体（如铃铛）来制造警报。
We associate these archaic noises like bells and whistles and sirens and kaxons with auditory alarms because that's just what the technology at the time allowed for and we got used to it. So Judy made actually this kind of funny point which is that we have such a narrow idea of what an alarm should sound like that it even shows up in futuristic sci-fi movies. Sci-fi films, all sorts of wonderful things happen in the film. But when you've got alarms go off and they're just the same alarms that we're just used to. It's like in the film The Martian, right? They can do all these wonderful things in good Mars, but they can't design better alarms
我们将这些古老的噪音（如铃铛、哨子、警笛和喇叭）与听觉警报联系起来，因为那正是当时的技术所允许的，我们已经习惯了。所以朱迪提出了一个非常有趣的观点，那就是我们对警报应该听起来像什么的观念太狭隘了，以至于它甚至出现在未来的科幻电影中。科幻电影，电影里发生了各种美妙的事情。但当警报响起时，它们只是我们习惯的那些相同的警报。就像电影《火星救援》一样，对吧？他们可以在火星上做所有这些美妙的事情，但他们却设计不出比我们现在更好的警报。
than we've got now. That's a lot of alarm sounds. Yeah. They're lirty. And they all kind of sound the same. They're guys in trouble. Yeah. Totally. But yeah, but with digital sound, you know, so much more as possible, you can make an alarm sound like basically anything.
那真是太多的警报声了。是的。它们很吵。而且它们听起来都差不多。那是人们有麻烦了。是的。完全正确。但是，有了数字声音，你知道，更多的可能性出现了，你可以让警报听起来基本上像任何东西。
You can use music. Some people use tones or sequences or melodies. You can use sounds that are use sounds as real objects, doing real things. And we tend to refer to these as auditory icons, but really they're just metaphors. And I love this. I love the idea of auditory icons and metaphorical sounds.
你可以使用音乐。有些人使用音调、序列或旋律。你可以使用听起来像真实物体、做真实事情的声音。我们倾向于称这些为听觉图标，但实际上它们只是隐喻。我喜欢这个。我喜欢听觉图标和隐喻性声音的想法。
It's just really interesting and cool to me. So what's a good example of an auditory icon? Okay, so hospitals are notorious for having these terrible soundscapes because the sheer amount of alarms that are just constantly going off and like at all hours of the night. And they're all just beeps and tones that are kind of variations of each other.
这对我来说真的很有趣也很酷。那么听觉图标的一个好例子是什么？好的，医院以拥有这些可怕的声景而闻名，因为大量的警报声不断响起，而且在深夜的任何时候。它们都只是哔哔声和音调，彼此之间只是变体。
So Judy designed this new tone that's meant to be used when there's a problem related to a patient's medication. And this is how it works. What you might do is you would announce an alarm by using something like this. That gets your attention followed by... See? Yeah, I mean, that's interesting.
所以朱迪设计了这个新的音调，旨在用于与患者药物相关的问题时。这就是它的工作原理。你可能会做的是，你会用这样的东西来宣布警报。这会引起你的注意，接着是……看到了吗？是的，我的意思是，这很有趣。
So there's a little bit of an attention graver and then something metaphorical so you can really tell what it is. Right, the sound of the pill bottle kind of cues medication in your head so you kind of already know what the problem is before you even address it. What we find with these auditory icons is that they're very, very easy to learn. You just tell people once what they mean and then they're away. They've understood it. So instead of some generic and alarming alarm sound that could literally mean anything,
所以有一个小小的注意力吸引点，然后是一些隐喻性的东西，这样你就能真正分辨出它是什么。没错，药瓶的声音在你的脑海中提示了药物，所以你在处理问题之前就已经知道问题是什么了。我们发现这些听觉图标非常容易学习。你只需要告诉人们一次它们意味着什么，然后他们就记住了。他们已经理解了。所以，与其使用那种字面上可能意味着任何事情的通用且令人惊恐的警报声，
which is what happened at Three Mile Island, you can imagine these auditory icons that kind of communicate exactly what the problem is. So there wouldn't be this confusion about trying to decipher what this one tone means. Except for at Three Mile Island, when there was a hundred things going wrong, it would sound like a preschool classroom of sounds, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, of, yeah, you basically have to rethink an environment from the top down in terms of what it sounds like. Well, cool. Well, thank you so much. No, thank you. 99% of his book was produced this week by Vivienne Lay and edited by Nina Pautuck.
就像三哩岛发生的那样，你可以想象这些听觉图标，它们传达了问题的确切所在。这样就不会因为试图破译这一个音调意味着什么而产生困惑。除了在三哩岛，当有一百件事出错时，它听起来就像一个学前班的教室，充满了各种声音……是的，你基本上必须从上到下重新思考一个环境的声音。好吧，太酷了。非常感谢。不，谢谢你。本周99%的节目由薇薇安·雷制作，尼娜·波塔克（Nina Pautuck）编辑。
The Auditory Alarms mini-story was originally reported by Vivienne Lay and produced by Delaney Hall, mixed by Hazique Ben-A Ahmad Fareed and Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Hayshad, tape syncing by Catherine Monaghan. Kathy Too is our executive producer, Kurt Colston is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Laucham Adon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Madina, Sarah Bake, and me, Roman Mars.
听觉警报迷你故事最初由薇薇安·雷报道，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作，哈齐克·本-艾哈迈德·法里德（Hazique Ben-A Ahmad Fareed）和马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙德（Graham Hayshad）负责，磁带同步由凯瑟琳·莫纳汉（Catherine Monaghan）负责。凯西·图（Kathy Too）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯顿（Kurt Colston）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德·莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、劳查姆·阿顿（Laucham Adon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-麦地那（Jacob Maldonado-Madina）、莎拉·贝克（Sarah Bake）以及我，罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。
The 99% of his below-goat was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Tom Epstein and Michael Waters. Michael wrote all about Prop 65 for Vox, and if you want to read more, you can find a link to that article on our website. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I am a proud community owner.
99%的节目由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本周特别感谢汤姆·爱泼斯坦（Tom Epstein）和迈克尔·沃特斯（Michael Waters）。迈克尔为Vox撰写了关于第65号提案的所有内容，如果你想阅读更多信息，可以在我们的网站上找到该文章的链接。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。非常漂亮。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。奥克兰根足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。
Other teams may come and go, but the roots are Oakland first, always. You can find a link to us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. It's a great time over there. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
其他球队可能会来来去去，但根基永远是奥克兰。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们的链接，以及我们新的Discord服务器。那里很有趣。那里有链接，以及99PI的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。